...Mortgage advisors it is important to understand
they are often financially incentivised to
push you towards certain mortgages and often
they are the mortgages that are worse for you...
all right so um the most important thing almost
always on your mortgage is the interest rate
almost always. like a small difference becausethe
amounts the size of mortgages are normally solarge
like 0.1% or 0.5%make a massive
difference on your payments right
um sometimes what mortgage advisors
it is important to understand
they are often financially incentivized
to push you towards certain mortgages
and often they're the mortgages that are worse
for you it makes sense in a way right because
the banks want you to take a mortgage that
is badfor you, because that's good for them
so the banks incentivise your mortgage advisors to
pushyou towards mortgages that are bad for you
so what sometimes happens is for example
they'll say here's one mortgage which is a
15 year mortgage and has a high interest rate 3%
and then the total amount of interest
you pay is this amount (small) and here's another
mortgage which is a 35 year mortgage but the
rate is 2% and you pay way more because
it's a much longer term mortgage okay
people think oh well i'll take the short term
mortgage on the higher interest rate because
i'll pay less interest. that is exactly completely
the wrong thing to do but it looks good because
they'll show you a form and it'll say well this
is the amount of interest you found this mortgage
and that's the interest you'll pay on that mortgage
but the reason you're paying more interest on a
longer term mortgage because you're borrowing
money for a much much longer period of time
and that gives you money for a long period of time
and then you can do what you want with that money
you can invest the money or you could you could
buy more property basically it's valuable to have
that money the most important thing is to get the
lowest interest rate because then that means that
your monthly interest payment will be lower
um that's the number one most important thing
and also if we talk about financial advice for
ordinary people the very first thing you should
do if at all possible is go check your mortgage
because sometimes people take two year fixed rates
the rate run out, the rate runs out and it goes to
a much higher rate and it'll be superexpensive
refinance get the lowest rate you can, the most
important thing is pick the lowestinterest rate
it's not complicated okay so thenwe talk
about how long should the mortgage termbe?
There's 2 types of term - there's the termof the
fixed rate - if you take a 2 or 5 year fixed rate
and then there's the term of theoverall
mortgage which is 25, 35 years or whatever
um in terms of the rates um it's generally
best to pick whatever is the lowest rate
If a 5 year fix is only slightly higher than a
2 year fix it might be worth it just to lock
in security for longer period of time um really
depends on what's happening at the time but
don't pay too much to have a longer fix but in
terms of the overall term of the mortgage
it's actually better to have a longer
term of mortgage and some people don't
understand this intuitively because they see
well i'll pay more interest if i borrow the
money for longer period of time but if you
take a 35 year mortgage all that means is
you'll have a lower monthly repayment
but remember you always have theoption
of paying more every year if you want to
and if you are able to save more money
that'sa very sensible thing to do
is to pay your mortgage down
um but if you take a 25-year mortgage with higher
monthly payments you can't make those payments
lower if you want whereas if you have a 35-year
mortgage with low payments you can make those
payments higher if you want. So effectively you're
just choosing the maximum term that you're allowed
so if you take a 35 year mortgage nobody's
stopping you from paying off in 15 years but if
you take a 15 year mortgage you try and pay off
in 35 years you're going to be in trouble basically
so you should always take the longest possible
term and you should basically consider yourself
as an individual and as a family - do we want to
pay that mortgage off early? if you have the money
or do you want to invest in other investment you
know you might want to buy a house for your kids
you might want to buy build up
a stock and share portfolio so
if you borrow the money for longer then you can
still pay it off more quickly if you want but you
also have that money for a long period of time
youcan use it to create passive investments
you can buy more property for your kids
you can buy stocks& stocks
so always take the longermortgage
and then you have the choice of
paying off whenever you want within that time
don't take a shorter mortgage because if you need
more time it'll become more difficult to get it
housing could be so much more affordable wages
could be so much higher and we could have so
many more options in how we live our lives some
of them put a lot of money into paying economists
and think tanks to tell you that inequalityis
is important for the economy that is not true